[Musique]
quand nous voulons localiser des lieux
en géographie nous utilisons des
coordonnées géographiques
or il arrive que celles ci soient
mentionnés en degré minutes et secondes
il s'agit en fait du système vecta
jessiman chaque fois que vous allez
passer à l'unité supérieure a compté 1
degré en plus c'est parce que vous aurez
dépasser les 60 minutes et chaque fois
que vous dépasserez les 60 secondes vous
rajouterez une minute vous comptez
habituellement dans le système décimal
ici il s'agit du système ce texte avait
si mal ne faut pas être paniqué devant
cela parce que c'est très facile de
passer de l'un à l'autre
c'est ce que nous allons voir dans cette
vidéo un exemple pour montrer qu'il est
très facile de passer du système décimal
système c'est que ça j'ai du mal ici
voilà une coordonnées géographiques
fictif 30 350 7 degrés et je veux
connaître cette valeur en degré minute
seconde mêlée de grêle il reste des
degrés donc le 30 reste du 30 c'est le
0,3 157 qui restent qui me pose question
le 0 357 je vais simplement le x 60
pourquoi je veux passer en systèmes sexe
âge et si mal en bas 60 donc il suffit
du x 60
j'obtiens 21 42 le 21 ce sont les
minutes
il me reste un 0.42 attention je ne peux
pas mettre directement 42 secondes parce
que ce sont 11 0 points 42 minutes
je dois encore une fois x 60 pour
obtenir les seconds 0 42 x 60 25,2 j'ai
ici 25 secondes vous allez me dire après
le zéro le 02
là je pense que pour un cours de
géographie du secondaire on est déjà
suffisamment précis avec les degrés
minute seconde qu'on laisse tomber le
0,2 maintenant comment vais-je faire
pour passer ici du système sexage et si
mal cette fois vers le système décimal
attention c'est ça ça ressemble à ce que
je viens de faire
mais pas exactement à 100%
je prends donc
les deux grecs qui reste bien des degrés
et dans un premier temps je vais prendre
mes minute 56 minutes et je vais disait
viser cette fois au lieu de multiplier
je vais diviser cette fois par 60 0,93 à
3 3 3 les 23 secondes
je vais les diviser aussi mais je ne
vais pas là / 60 je vais les trolls /
3600 pourquoi mais parce qu'il ya 3600
secondes dans un degré si vous voulez
j'ai fait 60 x 60 fait bien 3600 jeudi
vise 23 par ceux ci et j'obtiens donc
deux valeurs je vais additionner les
deux valeurs donc je fais 0,93 3,33
plus la valeur 0 0 063 8 8 8 8 et
j'obtiens ici 0 939 cette tondeuse et
donc ça ce sont les décimales de la
coordonnées géographiques que je peut
réutiliser évidemment là on est déjà
avec 4 décimales quatre chiffres
derrière la virgule on est déjà dans un
degré de précision très important et on
n'ira jamais jusque là aux cours mais
comme ça vous avez compris j'espère que
cette vidéo vous sera utile si vous
l'avez apprécié
n'oubliez pas le pouce bleu pour les
questions les commentaires sont
possibles vous pouvez également vous
abonner à la chaîne la société ecc
vous trouverez plein de vidéos sur la
biographie et sur les sciences sociales
principe sur les playlists
logés au et l'associé tech un bon
travail et après bientôt